recently she saw her first ever qriket
match
in melbourne with die cook everyone
please welcome to the stage
emily thank you so much jared i had a
wonderful opportunity this past february
to visit the australia research council
for three weeks thanks for generous
funding from a sims which is the
australian research council center
of excellence for mathematical and
statistical frontiers and so this is a
grant that die cook and i received
as well as big thanks to my boss chris
spelinski who let me go
um and so this this work visualizing
multivariate spatio temporal data was
inspired by
one of my projects at atnt where you can
imagine this type of data is abundant
and really important
for applications like monitoring or our
network performance
um and so for the project that dai and i
are working on
that has since been taken over by way
how lee who's an honors research student
um and has expanded it significantly um
for his for his thesis this year
um the work that we have been doing has
focused on the australia wildfires
of this past um this past season from
2019 to 2020.
um so this was devastating in its
severity and its spread it made
international headlines for
um the the significant damage to
um property to wildfires
to wildlife as well as the impacts on
cities like melbourne where the the air
quality was very very poor
um the benefit to working with data like
this is there is so much open data
accessible
um to study the the relationships
between variables that may impact the
bush fire spread so
um you know these are the summer in
australia goes from about december to
february
um and so those are some of the hottest
months where things like lightning
strikes can really rip
through um forest areas that are
inaccessible to
fire stations and things like that um
and so visualization of this data is
itself really interesting because of the
scale of the resources that we have
to compare it to things like vegetation
the fire stations how far it is from
resources
water um all those sorts of things as
well as historical information on what
caused the fire
so there are actually people who after a
season um compile the logs from what was
the expected cause whether that was
lightning strike or human error
and you could imagine that between urban
and rural the the causes may be very
different
but it's not really ideal to only have
that for historical data especially when
these wildfires are happening the
ability to predict
fire risk for an area
has the impact for potential policy to
prevent major fires in the future
um and so that's what we're looking at
here is what is the visualization that
we can
consider that that combines these
sources of data in a way that
enables data analysis and eda for a fire
prediction
risk model so to do that instead of
using the historical log data
that we as of right now i think only
have available up to
august of 2019 instead what we can use
is the himawari 8 hotspot data which is
a japanese weather satellite that
essentially measures how hot the surface
of the earth is and
pixels are classified as hot spots if
they are particularly high
in a variable called firepower and so i
sort of think of it as heat radiance
and so there certainly can be pixels
that are show up as hot
based on things like chimneys volcanoes
um but
but that's sort of the the data that we
have to work with
um and so what we have here is a map of
victoria and so from that hot spot data
over the six months we're considering
there are almost 76 000 hot spots
detected in the state of victoria
um so melbourne is right down here um if
you're if you're curious
so we filtered to fire fire power
greater than 100 to sort of
filter out those things that that might
not actually be fires
and that being said though we want to be
able to track fires and so i want to
note first that this is a bad map
for a lot of reasons explained very
nicely in this article that i
included here namely looking at six
months of spatial data is not
fantastically helpful
um it also makes it look like all of
victoria is on fire
at some point and this isn't helpful
because we want to be able to parse out
when are fires happening and where
and the hot spots themselves you may
have a cluster of hot spots that
in layman's terms is the same fire that
here appears as multiple fires
so the first thing that we did to
process this data was consider
how to cluster those hot spots we do a
spatiotemporal clustering of hot spots
that we're writing up for a forthcoming
paper but the key idea is that we look
at discrete buckets of time
and hot spots that are within a certain
um
distance of each other and create these
connected component graphs
such that we can consider how they
change from one time point to the next
we then calculate the centroid of hot
spots in any one hour and consider that
to be the fire's location
on that time t said them so here's an
example of just over the course of
several hours
what these fires these individual
clusters look like over time and you can
sort of see how they move and morph and
grow
so now once we have those clusters we
are able to take those 76 000 distinct
hot spots and cluster them into 2
000 distinct fires and so now i've just
plotted the ignition points so that we
don't have fires that are represented
multiple times
and i've also faceted these by month so
small multiples is always a really nice
way to get started if you're trying to
splice up a spatial thing by time
and so that's what we've done here and
immediately there's kind of a nice
realization that the distribution is
very different in october
than it is in december and january um in
particular what
turns out to be happening here and what
this if you go and look into this like
why is that the case
it turns out that there is sort of
regulated um burning off
of brush and where you're allowed to
have campfires and things and that
period ends at the end of october
what you're seeing over here in december
and january these are some of the state
parks and really big forest areas
that are a result of the heat and the
lightning and things like that that
occurred
over the course of the summer so i just
want to mention at this point there's a
huge spectrum
between simple data analysis and
visualization
when you are trying to get a sense of a
data set you're working that you think
is a spatial component
versus like a really slick um
visualization dashboard where you work
with spatial data all the time and
this is your jam and i would say that
when i started this project i was
solidly in the first
category um and for the purpose of this
talk that's kind of who i'm speaking to
so sometimes you just want to get points
on a map you just want to be able to see
patterns and understand
relationships with other variables in
such a way that enables you to
to you know grow your model or inform
the variables that you're choosing to
consider for it so how does this eda
visualization that that we're trying to
build here
support our project goals well we
mentioned that we're trying to predict
ignition locations and that we have
satellite data to do that to monitor
and track the movement of these fires
that we've now identified
with this clustering algorithm and then
the key really is going to be to
understand the patterns among between
those variables that contribute to the
ignition
initial initial ignition and the
continued spread
um this is important implications for
resource allegation
allocation and future assistance for say
the fire stations as well as
keeping tabs on on problem spots or when
the weather changes and things like that
so let's just back up a second so i'm a
data scientist who doesn't work with
spatial all the time
how did i get the state of victoria on a
map and i was able to do so with just a
few lines of code here
and so this is the the map on the right
that the
the code on the left gives me and so
some of this might look familiar
um so i'm using just ggplot2
and this library our natural earth
contains vector geometry representations
of different countries and states within
those countries around the world
so it's really handy if you don't want
to have to go look for a shapefile
and things like that and when i say
vector data geometry what i mean
is everything starts with points so lats
and longs
and then line segments that connect
those points you can then build
geometries you can see here that the
coast of australia gets pretty detailed
in the points that we can plot for them
we then have two so once i have my
australia object
um i'm just saying plot it and then
using this thing called gmsf and so what
this does
i returned australia as what's called a
simple feature object
um and this is uh has become really
handy for working with spatial data
essentially gives you a
tidy data representation of your spatial
geometry
um and so let's take a look really quick
at what am i doing here that i'm
capturing australia this way let's look
at that australia object
what we have here is it's telling me
that australia is a simple feature
collection
and what that means is it's really a
combination of those points and those
lines and those polygons
that make up the shape of the country i
also have inter
information on attributes so in this
came in this case the name of those
states
as well as a list column of the simple
feature geometries
i also just want to point out that
native to our natural earth is the
coordinate reference system
and this has to do with how uh the
country is projected onto the map and
it's just important to know and so the
wgs84 datum here is a pretty standard
one
that's capturing a definition for the
earth's shape as an ellipsoid
um so there is i could give an entire
talk on that but i won't so i just want
to focus on
sort of what what this gets me and what
does it mean to be a multi-polygon
um the sf package has some really great
thing yet
explaining all of this stuff and so some
of the key geometries that you might see
again starting with really simple points
latitudes and longitudes
you can connect those into lines and in
this case the reason that the states are
multi-polygons
it's because you can have like different
cutouts or little islands or things that
need to be captured
so once i know that i can work with this
like a tidy data set i can then just
filter
to get victoria to where the name is
victoria and then that gmsf
piece of my code knows to look for this
geometry column
and plot whatever is there and so that's
super handy and pretty quick to get up
and running
so now we got victoria on a map so i
just filtered to again where that
attribute name
is victoria i include the gm sf
piece here and then instead of using
labeling latitude and longitude like i
did before
the theme map from gigi themes gives you
a really nice clean
outline of the thing that you're looking
at
so at this point the questions of
interest in how you choose to use that
shape
is going to inform what you're actually
looking at so before i look at the
spatial distribution of fires over time
and we can start to answer some
questions there
you may also be interested in the
trajectory of individual fires and so in
this case
that map background is really just to
anchor you in space
although you don't necessarily know what
is there so i know because i've looked
at a lot of these plots that
you know in this corner we have uh the
forest the forest and um
more rural areas um and then we can look
at things like you may be interested in
the individual trajectory of one of
these fires that we created
and there are tons of clustering
algorithms to compare trajectories and
things like that
it is all going to depend completely on
on your goal and what the question is
that you're trying to
ask and answer um so i mentioned that we
have
tons of data available to us to uh
to work with here and so i just want to
mention a few of those sources
so that and why this problem becomes
complicated for visualization
so we have the hotspot data we also have
the fire stations we have information on
daily weather so things like the
temperature wind speed solar exposure
with their rain
open street map provides us with
representations
of roads and things like that so we can
compare how
far is the hot spot to a road which
gives you a sense of um
you know rural versus um if it's farther
away from
from where people can reach it
historically as i mentioned we have the
origin of fire what might have caused it
whether it was accidental
lightning strike information recreation
sites or
maybe people have campfires as well as
the fuel layer so these are things like
uh brush and plant types that may catch
fire as well as their cover
coverage from an area and then again our
fire movement
so when you start to think about the
data structures you can build with this
um the very first one is just that we
have for every hour
as i mentioned um the fire id we have
its location things like fire power the
distance
the nearest fire station uh cfa stands
for country fire authority
um as well as the nearest one how far it
is from a road all of these sorts of
things
and then you may be thinking well maybe
it's actually better to characterize
each of those fires with summary
statistics
um and so instead of looking at its
trajectory hour over hour
maybe i want to know things like how
long did it burn how far did it go
um where did it start and how close was
it to people and things when it started
what is the maximum firepower it reached
um and then if you're depending on your
application um you may also decide to
associate
those fires themselves with a geographic
entity so in this case
maybe the cfa um and so this is where i
had previously mentioned resource
allocation it may be helpful to know
which ones are getting overwhelmed with
buyers in their area
so as you start to think about all of
the data that you have available
and all the variables that are there the
more questions you start to ask and the
number of potential
plots increases to infinity and this is
where it is so easy to get complete
analysis paralysis
um because especially once you get a map
involved it's like
you want to do all the things to sort of
capture everything that might be
interesting
and it turns out they're just kind of
slowing down going back for a second
keeping in mind who is the audience what
do you want them to know what might
appropriate graphics be and is
user interaction going to be helpful it
helps you focus
i think on on one of these data sets to
think about
and it turns out that you have three
different ways of thinking about your
data here
but they ultimately really come down to
the same data structure
so essentially what you have is an id
column which is your key
you have a time this can be a constant
step like we had our
um or it could be ragged you know maybe
if we had looked at the
fires over a different time period that
could it could be inconsistent there
um s1 and s2 are sort of like your
location your latin long if you will
and then v1 through vk are all
associated variables that you have
and so from that data schematic i showed
before you really can append
um variables of interest from those
various data sources
all associated with for example a fire
in an hour
or a cfa and um a day or a week or
whatever the case may be
and so now once we have a generalized
data structure it's more helpful to
think about kind of what are the
analytical tasks that you're going to
answer and this will inform the types of
visualizations you make
so in particular what we really want to
know is where are events happening in
space and time
and is there an association between a
variable a place and the time at which
it's happening
components of these tasks you can take a
variable and map it to a color or a
point on a line or a map
you can look at a time series where
you're looking at the variable across
time
by fire in this case or you can
summarize them
and this is where two i think it's so
easy to start to think i want to you
know map something to color and
something to size and something to shape
and
um at some point that becomes unhelpful
because you're just overloading the
viewer
and really picking apart the pieces you
want to look at can be really tricky
so simple in this case is better i think
and this is where wilkie has a really
great book that you can
view online where it talks about good
and bad data visualization aesthetics so
sort of going back to first principles
so now i want to look at how do you
interact with your data and i have two
ways that i'll show
um again keeping it simple building upon
layers
one package i've really been having fun
with is tmap
and so you can set up an interactive
viewing mode that
we can get for free a little bit sort of
what is where within that state of
victoria map
and so here all i'm doing is i'm
converting my data frame of initial
initial ignition locations to an sf
object
um i'm setting sort of a base layer of
what i want the
the image to be um we can look at
i'm just then adding on the same vic
object that i had before which will be
the shape and then i have now
i'm i'm just plotting um the active
hours is the
the shape the size of a bubble
and now let me just pull this over here
and so that what this allows us to do i
faceted so you can now look at
essentially those six plots that i had
before are now interactive
so i can zoom in and now i have a nice
view on the fact that over here
is all forest i can see where those
fires are occurring
on month over month and just a sense too
of where they're happening
um and so of course the ability to pan
and zoom is really fun and i love that
it keeps track of where your mouse is in
one window compared with where it is
in the rest of them i'll also just
briefly mention
so i really like making shiny apps um
let me go back to full screen really
quickly
um and this is where linked plots can
also be very helpful in keeping it
simple
so i'm just showing here fires that
started
um at the same time on a certain day
that was pretty bad
um and so i'm going to have the location
of those fires on the victoria map
and then a time series below it of the
fire power
and so i just wanted to show in the code
here that this stays pretty simple
um so we have uh just a basic gg plot
and then
i'm just using plotly and really
wrapping that and the linking part is
done with this highlight key so i'm
saying that to combine them
we're going to look at the fire id so
that when i brush on one thing it will
be highlighted in the other
and the types of things this inlet
allows you to see
that is quite handy is that you can
consider does firepower change
um depending on the location
um so if i look at these two fires i see
that firepower stayed low and they were
they didn't last very long
compared to what we know is over here uh
more of a that forest area these
last for a lot longer the firepower gets
higher they have more opportunity to
burn
and if i had time i would quickly change
the color on this and distance the road
you see that these are much farther
um from the road and so there are some
interesting patterns to
be seen by being able to to brush and
have representations come up in a
different plot
um a couple of fires over here we see
they last longer but they never get
particularly hot
so i might then want to go look at what
was the weather happening in those areas
um so i just wanted to mention some
talks and books that i found helpful as
i've been thinking about this again the
key points being keep it simple use what
you know
and just be aware of learning a little
bit more about simple features and
things like that
we had a really great mappy hour we
called it with our ladies new york city
a few months ago where we had
two great talks by ayanthe um good
awarded that and angela lee
um geocomputation with r has been a
really great online resource and
documentation for the packages i
mentioned are just fantastic
it may also be that shiny in particular
like at some point
just can't handle the scale of data that
you're sometimes working with
so i also just wanted to point out two
solutions outside of r that give a nice
scalability piece to spatiotemporal data
um the first is nano cubes which was
developed by some of my colleagues at at
t
labs and allows for really nice panning
and zooming with time
series representation below and then
uber came out with kepler gl
which is also really neat to work with
so those are nice extensions if
our kind of hits your hits a limit
somehow
and so once again i just want to thank
so much diane way how for all of their
help and work on this project
as well as asims for funding my my work
with them so thanks so much
thank you emily uh gis is so popular
nowadays
uh we actually we just had a workshop
this week as part of the workshops of
cass sakamoto
doing a whole day of gis and last year
we had